yeah gotta have evidence it's one of
these pegs
I don't ok ok enough of ok you happen to
be a traitor
I trust you following me for a very long
time now where's the traitor everyone's
here now your eyes I've stick it with
you is that a admission of helped yes it
is no CIO you're wounded - you took the
fall
see I don't know if you're trying to
lead me away so that you oh my god I'm
coming down if I no one shoots me I'll
shoot back yeah one two you were worried
about like Megan too much sound you get
what you pick up there
shoutbox of Mac them over here box of
Magnum condoms yeah they snort wait are
they real pigs
hey star would you hit them do they
actually I needed a do like pigs
you died
innocent this is spooky by the way
you're looking at me there
wait where'd the whole come from was
that always there I don't think you get
in a glass that's scary
don't go down there I'm going down there
don't show me I'm coming down don't
shoot me this is a traitor
[Laughter]
oh why didn't you say so the body killed
you I know you have schmutz I had my
chance a chance to destroy you
No you traitor
I know I believe yamimash I don't pay I
believe you Yami - together hey haven't
you seen like I promised you Matt person
from the bottom of my soul and it's a
very big salt
I am NOT the traitor okay TT right there
so you can shoot it while I'm in there
and you don't kill me because you're a
traitor what happens if I just hold this
grenade so what pass that it was either
yamimash remark - that's a grenade in my
head
and oh no you're talking about what
doesn't have a grenade out didn't have
any guns out then off to the fire I saw
the big I think it may have been I think
it may have been marked because I really
believe this point what what what how
could I possibly it's always mix and
then she turns out in the neck antennas
it's not me but you definitely roses a
lot
it sounds like minks you're not gonna
lose me this time it's pretty convincing
I gotta say thanks okay so go ahead hey
if you're if you're so convinced go
ahead take her out and then wolves we'll
see we'll see for sure I will do thanks
Claire got some unfinished business
[Laughter]
how are you
so it's either I think it's either mark
minks spoon or Yami uh-huh the crater
Debbie one everyone but you you try to
kill me and you will see I don't know
what staying in someone he's like
manipulating the environment quite
everything on a pressure plate
minx didn't actually kill me but God you
guys went for it the trader I think are
you floating because I'm a trader who
did was a fire to your house getting who
let it through this in synchrony which
is obviously you me yeah you why me
Jonas do you trust me yeah you wouldn't
kill me would you I would more showdown
quiet I think she's the traitor I mean
it's probably if the last rounds are of
any indication it's probably either
mange to work yeah yeah yeah okay thank
you thank you for doing that
okay alright
minx you're definitely the traitor I
think you are huh thanks tell him
it is so sparkly it sparkles I got like
I got I got 50,000 subscribers on
sparkles who as I thank me up on this
one
[Laughter]
traitors never win I was a traitor and I
won't do that to me that's very
disrespectful it's all the traitors
deserve
[Music]
I just get up to where I was trying to
go